es ist der größte fortschritt sein
galileo das sagen fachleute den neuen
daniel kmu teleskop sind jetzt bilder
der sonnenoberfläche gelungen die den
knapp 150 millionen kilometer entfernten
himmelskörpern so detailliert wie noch
nie zuvor zeigen diese erkenntnisse
könnten sogar helfen katastrophen auf
der erde zu verhindern klick zum science
fiction wiege täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts
los geht's aber herzlich willkommen
so haben wir die sonne tatsächlich noch
nie gesehen es ist der blick direkt in
einen fusionsreaktor und der ist
spektakulär
auf den ersten blick sehen die
strukturen auf den neuen fotos aus wie
wabernde zellen diese fotos zeigen das
heiße plasma dass die gesamte sonne
bedeckt heftige bewegungen sorgen dafür
dass die wärme vom sonnen inneren zu
ihrer oberfläche transportiert wird und
genau dadurch entsteht diese
zellstruktur in den helm zentren steigt
das heißt plasma auf und kühlt dann ab
später singt es in dunklen gasen unter
die oberfläche und diese zellen sind
gigantisch jeder einzelnen dieser
zellstrukturen hat die doppelte größe
von deutschland die aufnahmen stammen
aus dem neuen solar teleskop daniel kwk
est das sich in einer höhe von 3000
metern auf dem gipfel des hawaiianischen
bergs hacker auf der insel maui befindet
charakteristisch ist der vier meter hohe
hauptspiegel damit damit der weltweit
größte aller sonnenteleskop ist dieses
hoch auflösende teleskop ist gerade erst
in betrieb gegangen und mit seiner hilfe
soll eine ganz neue ära der sonnen
forschung eingeleitet werden es ist in
der lage eine 38.000 kilometer breite
region der sonne abzubilden also ein
sehr kleiner detaillierter ausschnitt
nach jeff koon einem astronomen der
universität von dabei sind die neuen
bilder zitat der größte sprung in der
fähigkeit der menschheit die sonne vom
boden aus zu untersuchen seit der zeit
galileo galileis er spricht von zitat
einer großen sache doch die strahlung
der sonne ist dabei eine riesige
herausforderung für das forschungsteam
denn sie fällt natürlich in das teleskop
und ihre enorme hitze greift die
instrumente an ein spezielles
kühlungssystem verhindert aber die
zerstörung
eine weitere herausforderung das
flimmern der luft auf der erde
denn dadurch sieht das teleskop die
sonne
verzerrt doch mit hilfe eines optischen
gerätes können diese verzerrung aus dem
gesamten daten herausgerechnet werden
astronomie teams weltweit erhoffen sich
viel von dem neuen solar teleskop denn
mit seiner hilfe könnten die fachleute
endlich der dynamik der sonne auf die
schliche kommen
enorm wichtig um ihre energetischen
ausbrüche vorherzusagen und mit den
sonnensturm auch dass daraus resultierte
weltraumwetter ab dem kommenden jahr
soll das teleskop innerhalb von
lediglich fünf jahren mehr daten liefern
als die gesamte forschung seit galileo
galilei und derzeit können fachleute 48
minuten sonnenaktivität voraussagen bald
sollen es 48 stunden seien dazu der us
astronom edmonton verglichen mit dem
stand der wettervorhersage auf der erde
hängen wir beim sonnenwetter mindestens
50 jahre hinterher das gute das neue
bodengestützte teleskop ist in der lage
die magnetfelder der sonnenkorona
abzubilden und genau hier kommen die
sonneneruptionen vor die auch
auswirkungen auf das leben auf der erde
nehmen können bei sonneneruptionen
handelt es sich um elektro magnetische
vorgänge innerhalb des sterns aus der
sonnenatmosphäre wird dabei eine
gigantische fontäne aus gas
herausgeschleudert die unvorstellbar
heiß ist die dabei ausgestoßenen
teilchen protonen können im weltall
geschwindigkeiten von mehreren millionen
stundenkilometern erreichen der abstand
zwischen sonne und erde beträgt 150
millionen kilometer dazu kommt die
schützende wirkung der erdatmosphäre
trotzdem hat die sonnenaktivität auch
folgen für uns sonneneruptionen formen
plasmawolken und dadurch entstehen
magnetische stürme in unserer
erdatmosphäre das problem
solche ausbrüche sind bisher nicht
wirklich vorauszusehen doch schon nach
acht minuten erreichen sonneneruptionen
die erde dann dringt röntgenstrahlung in
die ionosphäre ein und verändert die
eigenschaften so dass funkwellen sich
nicht mehr ausbreiten können vor allem
kurz und ultra kurzwellen sind betroffen
dort findet vor allem der amateur und
mobilfunk shop auch gps kann von
sonnenstürmen betroffen seien und das
strom- und kommunikationsnetz kann durch
die induzierten ströme gestört und
zerstört werden das ist absolut krass
der schaden für die wirtschaft und
infrastruktur wäre enorm und beträgt den
schätzungen nach zufolge acht bis 40
milliarden us-dollar in den usa nur
täglich es gibt auch einige
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die die sonnen ausbrüche mit
naturkatastrophen hier auf der erde in
verbindung setzen taifune erdbeben und
auch solche hurricanes wie hw
und immer könnten ihnen direkt folgen
von sonneneruptionen seinen eruptionen
sind demnach 20 der direkte auslöser
solcher naturkatastrophen
doch selbst kleine störungen der
sonnenaktivität könnten lokale
wetterbedingungen demnach verstärken ein
super wichtiger und spannender
forschungsbereich also und so wollen die
fachleute rund um das neue teleskop auch
mit ihren kolleginnen und kollegen der
packers soll ab ob der nasa und mit dem
solar orbiter der esa zusammen arbeiten
und ergebnisse verbinden diese beiden
raumsonden sollen in den kommenden
jahren spannende erkenntnisse zu den
magnetfeldern der sonne bringen
beispielsweise wie diese mit denen der
planeten interagieren und auch das d ksc
soll noch besser werden immer mehr neue
instrumente werden dafür in der nahen
zukunft in betrieb genommen unter
anderem mit dabei zwei infrarot
instrumente mit deren hilfe die
magnetische aktivität der sonne und
sonnenstürme vorhergesagt werden können
eines davon ist der lage den magnetismus
der sonne über die sichtbare
sonnenscheibe hinaus zu messen
das instrument ist knapp zwei tonnen
schwer was würde passieren wenn die
sonne verschwindet gute frage von ihs
kosmos anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren cooler neuer kanal bei 1.054
bis dann bleibt dran